[Music]
time now for morning rounds as we've
been reporting a mass exodus of
residents as managed to flee the
approaching hurricane Irma but many more
remain in its path of course aside from
immediate safety concerns there's the
issue of maintaining health during and
after the storm hits here to talk about
this is CBS News contributor dr. David
agus David good morning morning Dennis
we obviously talked about this in
relation to Harvey and the flooding but
when you go to Florida we don't even
know what's coming next you have a lot
of elderly residents what do you need to
have on you if you've got some of those
chronic health conditions so there are a
couple principles one is get all of your
medical information and try to put it
online so put it into Dropbox or
somewhere you can access it you're gonna
be somewhere apart from your doctor by
the way your doctor is also fleeing so
you can't call him or her so that
information and take two weeks your
medicines and put it in a ziplock back
don't let it get spoiled but take two
weeks don't take a day or two days take
a long amount did it in in Texas they've
announced there they're conducting
aerial mosquito spraying because of
Harvey are we gonna have the same thing
in Florida and how serious is this
mosquitoes love stagnant water and so
classically days after this mosquito
start breeding and mosquito is obviously
Zika West Nile virus we worry about it
spraying works it's spraying chemicals
so obviously they're dangerous to us
we're told that the dangers of the
mosquitoes are much greater than the
dangers of the chemicals but this is
going to be a big issue especially in
Florida where Zika was really prevalent
over the past year or so it may be too
late for people to start gathering food
water but going ahead what do they need
to keep in mind when it comes to food
and water in Florida so obviously lots
of food lots of water and if you're
staying there one of the things you can
do is take a coin and put it in your
freezer on a frozen glass of water and
then if you come back and that coin to
the bottom of the glass you know your
freezer thought and that food isn't any
good and so you know food spoils and
there's gonna be a large period with
electricity that we have to be aware of
so you need to watch out for that one of
the things that concerns me you
mentioned a lot of doctors are leaving
people are leaving if you need to see a
doctor in Florida what do you do well
the emergency room is gonna be closed
it's going to be very difficult but the
telemedicine companies have all stepped
up and said you can use telemedicine for
free so if your cell phone works or you
have a computer or you're someone from
Florida who's gone up to Georgia you can
talk to a doctor on these services and
they can give you advice over the
internet which is really great that
these companies have stepped up you know
when harvey happened i friend of mine a
doctor and texas called me said i'm
fleeing with my family can you talk to
my patients and i had a whole list of
patients to call and talk to for him
everybody needs to step up you know we
talked about this also with harvey
obviously this is a huge stress on
people there are you know mental health
concerns that go into this as well my
question we see it and that all of these
storms you get mental health issues
become problem and it's stress you're
not sleeping you're worried so we all
have to take care of it after each other
and look after and then if family
members call your family's from florida
talk to them and try to settle them down
we all have to work as a team all right
dr. David agus thanks very much thank
you guys